all right so merry Christmas to you all  and at this time of year I'm so grateful  so so many people in my life but  especially the people who are in the  background and help us here at Fox News  in New York and so I just want to say  thank you to all those folks here I am  with here with Maura who's up on the  17th for reception she's been here I am  with Khadijah oh that's not good DJ yeah  yeah up not 17 there was daytime  receptionist here amber three-fight who  takes care of our lobby keeps it so  popular here I am with the makeup people  on 12 who take good care of me all right  and here I am with two of my favorites  Michelle and Jojo just the most  wonderful warm people  thank you all the eyes are the best your  jacket it was interesting all right